es un problema urgente y diario para los
afganos la falta de comida y bienes
básicos las naciones unidas se
comprometieron a seguir con sus
operaciones pero los fondos de la
oficina para la coordinación de asuntos
humanitarios enfrentan un déficit de
millones de dólares
américo las operaciones para suministrar
bienes médicos y humanitarios además de
otros materiales y apoyos siguen en
marcha pero se necesitan más recursos la
oficina de asuntos humanitarios necesita
1300 millones de dólares y sólo tienen
un 39 por ciento de los fondos y nine
present
unos 18 millones de personas casi la
mitad de la población necesita ayuda
humanitaria para sobrevivir
1 de cada 3 afganos no sabe cómo
conseguir su próxima comida y la mitad
de los niños menores de 5 años podrían
quedar mal nutridos durante el próximo
año
una crisis que se acentúa con el riesgo
de desplome económico
el año pasado la ayuda internacional
supuso más del 40 por ciento del pib del
país según el banco mundial pero el
flujo de dinero está disminuyendo
mientras los países e instituciones
internacionales deciden si reconocer a
los talibanes
eeuu ya ha congelado las reservas del
gobierno afgano y el fondo monetario
internacional ha bloqueado el acceso del
país a las reservas de emergencia
mientras tanto muchos bancos afganos
están cerrados y otros limitan los
retiros provocando largas colas en los
cajeros de residentes que buscan
efectivo desesperadamente del caribe
medio atada a la que no hay trabajo por
eso la gente está preocupada los
talibanes deberían intentar crear
trabajos y abrir la puerta a la
educación
los talibanes además tendrán que
responder a una crisis de desplazados
según la agencia de la onu para los
refugiados
400.000 afganos han sido desplazados
internamente desde el inicio del año